تؤكد ان طائرتها ستواصل التحليق فوق
المياه الدوليه في البحر الاسود بعد حادث
المسيره الامريكيه
وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه تتحدث عن اطلاق
ذخيره تحتوي الفسفور الابيض على مدينه
مجاوره لباخ
رئيس المصرف الوصي على بنك سيليكون
فاليمونهار يحض المودعين على العوده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر في
تطور لافت وخطير اعلنت القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه الاوروبيه انها اضطرت الى اسقاط
طائره مسيره من طراز ريبر كانت في مهمه
الروتينيه فوق البحر الاسود وقالت القياده
الامريكيه ان مقاتلات روسيه نفذت اعتراضا
غير امن الامر الذي كاد ان يتسبب في اسقاط
مقاتله الروسيه والمسيره الامريكيه مشيره
الى انها اضطرت لاسقاط المسيره تجنبا
للحادث
في الاثناء قال المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي بالبيت الابيض جون كيربي
في افاده صحفيه قال ان الرئيس جو بايدن
على علم باستظام المقاتل الروسيه والمسيره
الامريكيه فوق البحر الاسود واعتبر كير
بان اعتراض المقاتل الروسيه المسيره كان
غير امن وغير احترافيه مضيفا ان مسيره
الامريكيه لم تشكل اي تهديد وكانت تقوم
بمهمه في الاجواء الدوليه وشدد كيربي على
ان الولايات المتحده ستواصل خدمه مصالحها
الامنيه في البحر الاسود مشيرا الى ان
واشنطن لا تحتاج الى تنسيق مع روسيا عندما
تقوم بالتحليق فوق البحر الاسود
وفي تعليقه بعد استدعاء وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه له عقيبه حدث اصطدام المقاتله
الروسيه بالمسيره الامريكيه فوق البحر
الاسود قال السفير الروسيه في واشنطنوف ان
وجود مسيره امريكيه في البحر الاسود يعد
عملا استفزازيا اضافه بان المقاتلات
الروسيه لم تستخدم اي اسلحه خلال مواجهتها
مع المسيره مشيرا في الوقت ذاته الى ان
موسكو لا تسعى الى صدام مع واشنطن
اما وزاره الدفاع الروسيه فنفت روايه
البنتاجون بشان حادثه اسقاط طائره مسيره
امريكيه فوق البحر الاسود وقالت ان مسيره
الامريكيه اقتربت من المجال الجوي الروسي
فوق شبه جزيره القرم حسب بيانها واضافت
الوزاره بان مسيره الامريكيه اغلقت اجهزه
تعريفها فانطلقت مقاتلات روسيه كانت في
مهمه في المنطقه الى موقع مسيره ونفت
الدفاع الروسيه ان تكون مقاتلاتها استخدمت
الذخيره ضد المسيره الامريكيه او قامت
بالاقتراب بشكل خطير منها مشيره الى ان
مسيره قامت بمناوره حاده تسببت في خسارتها
لارتفاعها وفقدانها السيطره لينتهي بها
الامر بالارتطام بسطح البحر
في المقابل اكد المتحدث بالنسبه لبنتاجون
انه لن يفضح تفاصيل المعدات والمهمه التي
كانت تقوم بها مسيره الامريكيه في البحر
الاسود واوضح رايدر بان روسيا لم تعثر على
المسيره بعد سقوطها
في تفاصيل المعدات التي كانت على متن
الطائره المسيره كانت وحده مراقبه وبسبب
الضرر كنا في موقف دفعنا لتحطيمها في
البحر الاسود على حد علمي الروس لم
يستعيدوا هذه الطائره وعن جهود استعادتنا
لا توجد معلومات حتى الان ونقيم الموارد
التي لدينا في هذه المنطقه
المتحدث باسم البيت الابيض او باسم
البنتاجون ذكر ان المقاتلات الروسيه القت
الوقود امام المسيره الامريكيه فوق البحر
الاسود مشيرا الى ان مقاتلات روسيا اقتربت
بشده من المسيره حتى تسببت في اضرار لها
ينورك
نواصل تقييم ما حدث ولكن اعتقد حسب تصرفات
الطيارين الروس كان ما فعلوه امرا غير امن
وغير احترافي اعتقد ان تصرفاتهم تتحدث عن
نفسها ما رايناه هو ان المقاتلات القت
الوقود امام الطائره المسيره واقتربت بشده
منها حتى تسببت في اضرار لها نقيم ان ذلك
تسبب في ضرر للطائره الروسيه ايضا حسب
معلوماتنا المقاتله الروسيه هبطت لاحقا
ولن نقول اين هبطت ولكن هذا يظهر كيف كان
الطيارون غير محترفين
بان القوات الروسيه اطلقت ذخيره تحتوي على
ماده الفسفور على منطقه غير ماهوله في
مدينه تشاسيف يار قرب مدينه باخموت التي
تشهد اعنف المعارك بين القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه وبحسب وكاله الانباء تسببت
كرات الفسفور بحرائق في المساحات المزروعه
على جانبي الطريق في الضواحي الجنوبيه
لمدينه تشيلسي فيار ولم يتسنى لفرنس برنس
التاكد مما اذا كان الموقع مستهدف مركزا
للقوات الاوكرانيه وتنتهم موسكو بانها
استخدمت هذا النوع من الاسلحه مرارا منذ
بدء الحرب بما في ذلك ضد مدنيين وهو ما
فيه الجيش الروسي
بشده
قال الرئيس فاجنر التي تقاتل قواته على
الخطوط الاماميه مع الروس ان المعارك في
باخ متزاد وقسوه كلما اقتربت قواته من وسط
المدينه مؤكدا ان قواته تواجه مقاومه شرسه
وان الوضع في ضخمه صعب للغايه واضاف بان
الاوكرانيين يلقون باحتياطيات لا نهايه
لها في المعركه مشيرا الى وجود حوالي 70
الف جندي اوكراني في باخمت ومحيطها
في الاثناء خلال الاجتماع مع قادته
العسكريين قرر الرئيس الاوكراني استمرار
الدفاع عن ضخمك مشيرا في بيان الى ان هذا
القرار اتخذ بالاجماع وانه لا تنازل عن
المدينه ياتي هذا الموقف رغم تقرير
الامريكيه عديده عن نصيحه واشنطن لكييف
بالتخلي عن المدينه
قال تقرير لصحيفه واشنطن بوست ان القوه
العسكريه لاوكرانيا متدهوره بعد عام من
الحرب اذ تدور الشكوك حول قدره كياف في شن
هجوم خلال الربيع المقبل
بين هذه الخطوط والعاصمه كييف يدور شك في
قدره الاخيره على شن هجوم مضاد في الربيع
كما قالت وتتحضر
فعام من الحرب انهت جيشها وافقده الاافا
من ذوي الخبره القتاليه
في احدث التقارير الغربيه فان حاله القوه
العسكريه الاوكرانيه متدهوره بسبب حجم
الاصابات التي اخرجت العديد من المقاتلين
الاكثر خبره من ساحه المعركه
يرجع مسؤولون اوروبيون وامريكيون حاله
التدهور هذه لعده اسباب
فخلال عام وقع 120 الف جندي اوكراني بين
قتيل وجريح جلهم من ذوي الخبره القتاليه
حجم الخساره هذا دفع كييف للدفع بمجندين
عديم الخبره لسد النقص على خطوط القتال
اضافه للنقص الاساسي في الذخيره
وفقا لصحيفه واشنطن بوست فان الاشهر
القادمه تشكل تحديا امام كييف لاستعاده
زمام المبادره وشن هجوم في هذا الوضع الذي
يعاني فيه جيشها من نقص في العدد والعتاد
بالمقابل فان حال الجيش الروسي ليس بافضل
حال وان كان عدده يشكل ثلاثه اضعاف جيش
اوكرانيا
فوافقا للتقديرات الغربيه ذاتها فقد خسرت
موسكو قرابه 200 الف جندي بين قتيل وجريح
اضافه لمشاكل في الذخيره والقوى العامله
وما بين تشكيك بقدره كييف وموسكو على
الهجوم والدفاع فان التقديرات تقول ان
عاما من الحرب انهك الجيشين وان عاما
جديدا بدا لتوهه ايضا بالحديد والنار
امر وزير الدفاع الروسي سرقه بمضاعفه
انتاج الاسلحه التكتيكيه عاليه الدقه
وخلال زيارته الى شركه الاسلحه الصاروخيه
التكتيكيه قال ان الشركه تفي بمتطلبات
الانتاج المحلي لكنها تنتظر تحديات مضاعفه
بالانتاج او مضاعفه الانتاج واعتبر انا
مؤسسه تمتلك كل الاحتياطيات الضروريه من
المتخصصين ذوي المؤهلات العاليه والمنشات
ومرافق لتنفيذ مهمتها
قالت الامم المتحده ان المشاورات بشان
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه مستمره على
جميع المستويات وذلك بعد ان وافقت روسيا
على تمديد صفقه تصدير الحبوب لمده شهرين
فقط بدلا من اربعه اشهر
تلاحظ الامم المتحده الاعلان الذي اصدره
الاتحاد الروسي بشان تمديد مبادره حبوب
البحر الاسود لمده 60 يوما نحن بصفتنا
مكتبه تنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه ندعم
بالكامل ما قاله الامين العام امس عن ان
الامم المتحده ستبذل قصارى جهدها للحفاظ
على سلامه هذا الاتفاق وضمان استمراريته
ويمكنني ان اضيف اليوم ان الاجتماع مع
الاتحاد الروسي هنا في جنيف اختتم امس كما
تم الاتفاق عليه ولكن المشاورات مستمره
على جميع المستويات
رئيس بنك سيليكون فالي بريج الذي انشاته
السلطات المصرفيه الامريكيه حديثا ونقلت
اليه كافه ودائع البنك المنهار حظ جميع
العملاء على اعاده ايداع الاموال التي
قاموا بسحبها حتى يتمكن البنك من العمل
مجددا وقال تم مايبروس الرئيس التنفيذي
البنك في بيان ان الامر الاول الذي يمكنكم
القيام به لدعم مستقبل هذه المؤسسه
مساعدتنا في اعاده بناء قاعده الودائع
لدينا وذلك سواء عبر ترك الودائع لدى بنك
سيليكون فالي بريد او اعاده تحويل الودائع
التي سحبت خلال الايام الماضيه واضاف نحن
نفعل كل ما بوسعنا لاعاده البناء ونيل
ثقتكم مجددا ومواصله دعم اقتصاد الابتكار
وكانت صحيفه نقلت عن مصادر مطلعه قولها ان
وزاره العدل الامريكيه وهيئه البورصات
الامريكيه تحققان في انهيار بنك سيليكون
فالي واوضحت المصادر ان التحقيقات ما زالت
في مراحلها الاولى وقد لا تؤدي الى
اتهامات او مزاعم بارتكاب مخالفات واصبحت
مجموعه اس اف بي الماليه اكبر بنك ينهار
منذ الازمه الماليه عام 2008 واثار قلق
الاسواق وترك مصير مليارات الدولارات
التابعه لشركات ومستثمرين معلقا
وكانت حده المخاوف الامريكيه من حدوث ازمه
شامله في القطاع المصرفيه هدات وتحول
المستثمرون الى اسهم البنوك من جديد بعد
ان تراجعت على مدار ثلاث جلسات متتاليه
الاجراءات التي اتخذها الفيدرالي والتي
كان من اهمها ضمان ودائع بنكي سيليكون
فالي
وسكنيك المتعثرين ساهمت في اعاده بعض
الثقه للقطع
من جهه اخرى اعلن الرئيس التنفيذ الجديد
الكيان الجديد المؤسس تحت شركه التامين
على الودائع الفيدراليه والذي تم نقل جميع
ودائع واصول البنك المتعثر اليه اكد اعاده
مزاوله الاعمال داخل الولايات المتحده
مشيرا الى ان الاعمال عبر الحدود ستستانف
في الايام المقبله واكد ان الموعين
المذيعين يمكنهم الوصول الى اموالهم كما
ان الوداع الجديده والقائمه محميه بالكامل
خلال مؤتمر صحفي في برلين مستشفى الالماني
بشان صحه البنوك في البلاد بعد ان اثار
انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي مخاوف من انتشار
الاسماء
يمكنكم ان تروا من خلال رد الفعل الواضح
والحاد للسلطات الامريكيه والبريطانيه
والاوروبيه وكذلك الالمانيه ان هذا الوضع
يخضع لمراقبه دقيقه للغايه وان هذا
الاجراء يتم اتخاذه بسرعه كبيره وهذا افضل
شيء يمكن القيام به من اجل سلامه الودائع
لذلك لا يوجد سبب لاي شخص هنا في المانيا
ليكون قلقا للغايه
مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
وزير الطاقه السعوديه يقول ان السعوديه لن
تبيع البترول لاي دوله تفرض سقف اسعار على
امداداتها
الامير عبد العزيز بن سلمان ان المملكه لن
تبيع البترول الى اي دوله تفرض سقف اسعار
على امداداتها واكد في لقاء مع انرجي
بان السعوديه ستخفضه انتاجها اذا تم وضع
سقف لاسعار النفط مشيرا الى انه لن تستغرب
المملكه اذا قامت الدول الاخرى بنفس
الاجراء وزير الطاقه السعوديه اضافه بان
مشروع قانون نوبيك الامريكي سيتسبب في
انخفاض العرض العالمي بشده على الطلب في
المستقبل موضحا ان السياسات فرض سقف على
اسعار نفسه تؤدي الى محاله الى تفاقم عدم
استقرار السوق وتقلباته واكد وزير الطاقه
السعوديه العزم على الابقاء على الاتفاقيه
اوبك لخفض الانتاج حتى نهايه العام الحالي
افادت مصادر قضائيه لبنانيه للعربيه بانه
ستعقد اليوم جلسه استجواب لحاكم مصرف
لبنان رياض سلامه امام القاضي شربل ابو
سمره في قضايا اختلاس اموال عامه مضيفه ان
الجلسه ستتم في قصر عادل بيروت واكد
المصدر ذاته انه من المنتظر ان يحضر سلامه
شخصيا الجلسه لان وكلاء هو القانونيين لم
يقدموا دفوعا شكليه بحضورهم نيابه عنه
وانا التحقيق معه سيكون بحضور قادم فرنسي
من ضمن وفد المحققين الاوروبيين الموجودين
في لبنان
يعيش السوريون الناجون من الانسان المدمر
في شمال غرب سوريا حاله اضطراب ما بعد
الصدمه حيث يرفض الكثير منهم العوده الى
منازلهم رغم انها لم تتضرر ويعزل مختصون
نفسيون ذلك لهول المشهد لحظه وقوع الكارثه
ترقد تحت هذا الركام احلام قتلت ففي كل
منزل قصص وحكايا دفنت مع ابطالها صغارا
كانوا او كبارا اما الناجون فيلاحقهم
الخوف والرعب وبات العيش بين الجدران
كابوسا يؤرقهم مهند شاب سوري فقد اخويه
تحت الانقاض وعاش مع عائلته لولا اللحظات
الاولى لتارثه ورغم عدن تضرر منزله بات
يخشى العوده اليه لتغدو هذه الخيمه
مستقرهم الاشاعات اللي صارت الضعف
المعلومات اللي عنا الجيولوجيه اللي نحن
ما بنعرف عنها شيء ابائنا واجدادنا مع شو
هاي الفتره اللي صارت فنحن عنا خوف مكبوت
ما عم نفرجيه للاولاد للعيال فانا كيف بدي
اقنع عيلتي انه نروح نسكن وانا في عندي
خوف بداخلي من هذا اللي راح يصير يعزل
مختصون ارتفاع احصائيه الاصابه اضطراب ما
بعد الصدمه خصوصا بين الاطفال في عموم
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال الى ما عاشه
السكان من خوف وذعر منذ لحظاته الاولى في
ناس تقريبا اصيبوا في هذا المرض وطبعا
النصيحه وهو هذا الاهم هو حسب تعامل الاهل
مع هذا الطفل او هذا الشخص اللي اصيب بهذا
المرض طبعا في عنا خطين خط الاول هو الاخذ
لطبيب نفسي والخط الثاني انه المعالجه
الشخصي بالبيت في ظل غيابي مراكز الصحه
النفسيه عن المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال
المدمر ومراكز الايواء والمخيمات يؤكد
ناشطون على ضروره العمل الجاد لاخراج
الناجين من هذا الاضطراب الذي اصاب
الكثيرين منهم ما بين مطرقه قصف النظام
والميليشيات الايرانيه على مدار سنوات
وسندان الخوف والمعاناه والنزوح اثر
الزلزال تستمر ماساه السوريين الذين باتت
الخيام اقصى احلامهم رغم ان قماشها لا يقي
برد الشتاء ولا حر الصيف محمد الاشقر
العربيه مدينه ادلب
يعكس الهجوم العنيف الاخير الذي شنه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب على
حاكم فلوريدا احتدام المنافسه بين الرجلين
كما يبرز الهجوم مخاوف ترامب بشان احرازه
تقدما لدى الناخبين الجمهوريين رغم ان
معظم استطلاعات تظهر تقدم الرئيس السابق
على منافسه المحتمل لدى القاعده الشعبيه
في الحزب
وعند السيد
بسخريته المعتاده من خصومه شن الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب هجوما عنيفا
على حاكم فلوريدا سانتوس
ترامب الاخير جاء خلال تجمع الانتخابي
للجمهوريين في مدينه دافن بورد في ولايه
ايوا حاول خلاله ابطاء صعود نجم ديستانتاس
منافسه الرئيسي المحتمل في الحزب الجمهوري
الذي زار المدينه قبل ايام
الاستطلاع يقول ان ترامب لا يزال يتمتع
بمعدلات موافقه عاليه في قاعده الناخبين
الجمهوريين ويتفوق على الروندي سانتوس في
استطلاع تلو الاخر وانا اتغلب على جو بايد
كثيرا وهذا مهم جدا
وقبل ذلك صرح ترامب لصحافيين على متن
طائرته بانه ندم على تاييد
واصفا اياه بانه غير مخلص وبانه كان ميتا
كالكلب مضيفا بان حياته السياسيه كانت
ستنتهي لو لم يؤيد حملته عام 2018
من الحصول على اي زخم انتخابيه والبدء
بزياده عدد مؤيديها لذلك يريد ايقافه قبل
ان يبدا
وبشان تصريحات نائب الرئيس السابق بان
التاريخ سيحاسب ترامب على هجوم الكابيتول
اعتبر ترامب بان بانس كان مسؤولا عن اعمال
العنف في السادس من يناير عام 2021
كان من اللافته ان ترامب لم يهاجم بانس
بالحده ذاتها التي هاجم فيها ديسمبر رغم
ان الاول انتقده والثاني يتجاهله حتى الان
وهو ما يراه البعض مؤشرا على مخاوف ترامب
بشان حاكم فلوريدا الذي ينظر اليه على انه
اخطر منافسيه حسين الطاوضه العربيه واشنطن
بعد سته اشهر لا تزال الاحتجاجات التي عمت
شوارع الايرانيه منذ مقتل الشاب الكرديه
محسن اميني مستمره
نهسى اميني شعله لم تنطفئ في ايران بعد
سته اشهر على مقتلها اتهمت بانها ترتدي
لباسا غير لائق ثم اقتيدت الى مركز الشرطه
ثم قتلت
لتسبب وفاتها موجه احتجاجات لا تزال
مستمره حتى اليوم
فالاصوات التي ملات شوارع المدن الايرانيه
لا مطلب لها سوى العداله والحريه
والمساواه
الغضب الذي اشعلته وفاه مهسا ترافق مع
سلسله مشاكل خصوصا الازمه الاقتصاديه
وسلوك شرطه الاخلاق
احتجاجات اعتقل فيها الالاف واعدم العشرات
في خطوه قالت المعارضه انها لترهيب
المحتجين
في ظل حربها مستمره على المراه اغلقت حركه
طالبان المكتبه النسائيه الوحيده في
العاصمه كابول بعد سته اشهر فقط على
افتتاحها
حتى المكتبه هنا في كابول لم تسلم طالما
ارتبط اسمها بالنساء فحرب طالبان على
المراه لم تتوقف بعد وتطال كل ما يتعلق
بها
في احدث فصول هذه الحرب اقدمت حركه طالبان
على اغلاق المكتبه النسائيه الوحيده في
العاصمه الافغانيه بعد سته اشهر فقط من
افتتاحها مسؤول المكتبه قالوا انهم
اغلقوها لاسباب امنيه وفرض قيود على
النساء من قبل حركه طالبان الى جانب تعرض
المكتبه للهجوم مرتين من قبل طالبان
لتنتهي القصه باغلاقها نهائيه
اغلاق المكتبه التي شكلت الملجا الوحيد
للفتيات في كابو يقابله اصرار من النساء
على افتتاح مكتبات سريه ردا على اقصاء
طالبان الممنهج له مع التوجه الحاد للحركه
في القضاء على حقوق المراه تتضائل الامال
في تاثير التحركات الدوليه للضغط على
السلطه حرمت النساء ليس من العمل والتعليم
فقط بل وحتى ارتياد المرافق العامه
والترفيهيه في اخر تحرك دولي تجاه ما
تمارسه الحركه فرض الاتحاد الاوروبي في
الثامن من الشهر الجاري عقوبات عن وزير
التعليم العالي في طالبان لدى محمد نديم
بسبب مسئوليته عن الانتهاك الواسع لحق
المراه في التعليم وزير اعلن علنا انه
يريد قتل كل ما يخالفه
في نهايه نذكره بابرز ما جاء فيها من
العناوين
واشنطن تؤكد ان طائرتها او طائراتها
ستواصل التحليقه فوق المياه الدوليه في
البحر الاسود بعد حادث المسيره الامريكيه
وكانت الصحافه الفرنسيه تتحدث عن اطلاق
ذخيره تحتوي الفسفور الابيض على مدينه
مجاوره لباخ
رئيس المصرف الوصي على بنك سيليكون فالي
المنهار يحض المودعين على العوده للبنك
وايداعي اموالهم
بالعناوين نصل مشاهدين
يتجدد بحول الله عند المنتصف الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]